a little bit about ice cream planet who
we are we think about us to think about
the company it takes that a single
broadcast feed and then transforms that
in for distribution for all these
different devices so if you pick up NBC
live sports extra app for example you're
watching a Premier League or you're
watching NFL or you're watching NBA or
or Formula One or any number of
different sports that we support an
ongoing basis we're responsible for
taking that broadcast feed conditioning
inserting all the ads all the closed
captioning providing all the security in
the are destroyed its management
encryption and then conditioning
conditioning that stream once again
especially for different different sets
of devices by creating different
playlists all these different devices
and we do this on a daily basis for
something close to about 200 many other
channels that we operate today and
approximately 250 different live events
anything from all these premium sports
and media brands that you see here on
the screen so what's new in a market
space and why are we so excited to be
collaborating with Google really when
what led us to Google I think it's hard
hard not to notice that all these
announced was new exciting announcements
about a TV finally getting transformed
after all these decades seeing the same
stuff a set-top box remote control very
very very slow user guide and and limit
their number of channels or certain
bundles and then all of a sudden what
happens is HBO announces they're going
over the top you can subscribe and you
can watch all the great content HBO
produces and creates for us live and
on-demand and you don't need a cable
cable subscription and then many others
follow today's sling TV which is a
product of the dish creates what we call
a skinny bundle launches on bundles
bunch of channels creates a pretty
compelling bundle it probably 80% of us
use on a daily basis and makes it
available to us over the top on any
device and and many others
now as exciting as that is there really
are three big challenges and instead of
talking about these challenges I'm going
to tell
little story it is 2010 and we're
getting ready it's January 2000 of
January 2010 and we're getting ready to
a stream of Vancouver Olympics for first
time in HD and we have 28 different
different live sources coming all the
way from Vancouver NBC and and
Netherlands because we had three
different broadcasters that we're
working with as well as the Canadian
folks we had six channels from Canada
and I remember going back home it's
about three o'clock in the morning at
the one of those long long long long
days during my Cox cable and there was
only 16 HD channels at the time we're
running 28 of these channels for 18 days
and about 3,000 live events covering
every single second of the games but
really the point I'm trying to make is
about a week prior to the Olympics we
get a call from two more broadcasters
and when they told me they said me oh we
need 10 more sources and how much is
gonna cost and I said I can't do it and
they said what do you mean you can do it
we'll pay you $100,000 for each one of
these sources I say I like if you pay me
a billion dollars I can't do it unless I
take away from hardware software and all
the cabling and everything else that we
have allocated for our current customers
it would take me approximately six weeks
to procure the equipment it would take
me another four weeks to to get
everything cabled up powered up and
turned on and then get every probably
another two to three weeks to get
everything integrated with end to end
workflow and in the meantime Olympics
will be long gone so needless to say we
did not end up providing services for
these traditional broadcasters but then
left an impactful thought in my mind
that we didn't have a scale we didn't
have not only that we didn't have a
scale but we did not have ability to
elastically scale based on demand the
complexity of workflow was too too high
too long it took too long to to
provision things and all these different
hardware all these different appliances
that that take to to organize this
premium content deliver across these
different devices they're very expensive
each one of these boxes are twenty
thirty thirty to twenty to thirty
thousand dollars and you gotta integrate
them and cabling at time and everything
else obviously there was a huge problem
we did is we set on to solve this
problem a part of the vision was how do
we move all this complex workflow all
inside the software so we don't have
three or four different appliances
performing different tasks we don't have
a surrender pricebuster try and tries to
connect all these all these different
systems you know how do we lower the
cost of doing doing all this and how do
we scale dynamically so if it's Olympics
time then we need to go for example for
real we're going to have something close
to a hundred different feeds now on a
regular day our customer NBC for example
uses something like sixteen to twenty
feeds but during those 18 days they're
gonna need an additional 100 feeds how
do we turn them up spin them up they
operate for about 18 days process every
single second of the games and then on
day 19 they go down they disappear and
the best of all customer only pays for
those 18 days what they used so what we
created what we call a Ventus it's our
platform it's our product it's the
world's first fully distributed product
built 100% for a cloud solely for a
cloud it's a distributed distributed
architecture allows us to acquire
scheduled acquire content process all
the content all the bits insert the ads
process all the closed captioning in
case there's any issues with any of the
parts of our workflow our system will
automatically detect that it will give
you the data in real time what's
happening from a moment we get the
content or the moment content gets
delivered to the end-users and then if
there's any problems we're gonna use all
this wonderful big data that we gather
and solve the problems on the fly and
that's that's what we do today with
Aventis and that's what we use for our
customers now why was Google really
interesting to us I think Chris from
vows and gentleman from fast I did a
great job talking about or IO and all
these sorts of things so I'm only gonna
focus on on the networking about us
about a nine months ago at this little
show called international broadcast
conference in in Amsterdam we probably
met with about 40 to 50 different
customers and a messaging was very loud
and clear to us how do we take advantage
of Aventis and all this great product
that you guys have bill
but we need in Australia we need it in
Singapore we need it in Japan we need it
in in Frankfurt all over in Europe and
Latin America Olympics are coming loud
in America how do we take advantage of
all these capabilities around the world
and then lastly is how do we do this
without spending a vast amount of money
egressing in ingesting this content into
the network this is a very very big
problem so when we when we open up these
discussions with Google and and it's
great to know that search and
advertising everybody else runs on this
platform which we can attest to it in
fact I'm gonna break this pattern I'm
actually gonna show you the demo the
actual demo of the product but it was
really really cool knowing that we can
ingest a gigabits of Giga bits of
content I'm talking about hundreds of
hundreds of channels or live linear
events into the Google cloud without
actually paying any extra cost if worth
a certain inter carrier partners which
was a huge value to us and our customers
so today we run a number of different
channels we're getting hurt actually -
we're actually kind of sort of in a beta
mode today in about 30 days we're gonna
be in a production we're looking to
launch just over about 500 channels over
the next 12 months and do about 3,000
live events a month on average to a
Google cloud platform but enough enough
about talking about this let's go and do
some demos and some fun stuff here and
actually show you some live video going
through google cloud platforms so I'm
gonna swap this thing out if that's ok
real quick and you gotta love it when
the CEO gives a demo that's what it's
all about you get it you get it you
gotta show people what we're doing and
why we're excited by Google let's see
there we go device drivers
okay so what are you looking at right
now is this is a very very simple
interface I mean we stole idea from you
guys Google search box there's just one
box very simple there's no 30 menus and
submenus so I'm going to create actually
a new channel I'm gonna call this a gtp
demo and sources we have various sources
so I'm gonna pick the the NBC Sports
Network sports is always more fun than
use out of our club video routers so we
also have a capability to route all
these video feeds and enter our cloud
video router which is a part of our
product we can send this to any of
Google clouds locations around the world
I'm gonna leave it a default preset
language I'll have a Ventus reconfigure
all that automatically for me and I'm
going to enable so instead of typing all
this data I have still NAB demo and I'm
gonna click on start Channel
so now what happens here is what what
I've done is essentially I've created a
adjacent payload that says go ahead and
find his source
subscribe to this particular source do
this particular encoding configuration
on it dynamically determine what kind of
source comes in what kind of outputs can
we create out of that and then create
HLS package in HLS format and that JSON
file gets sent out to to our cloud
orchestration layer and then
orchestration layer what our
construction layer does he unpacks that
and says okay well now I have you know
this kind of encoding these different
bit rates this kind of packaging this is
what my source is I need this much
computational power from Google well
it's too fast I can't even finish my
speech I'm sorry Dave
flood it works the clock works really
well so what it does it says I
essentially need this much CPU I need
this much storage I need this much
bandwidth egress and egress bandwidth
out in this case to Arkham I we haven't
not done a work yet but fast the
apologies for that will we should
probably talk afterwards
but we're publishing all this content to
Akamai and essentially creates this
channel on fly and what you're seeing
here
is and actually a preview so we're
generating a preview about every five
seconds we're generating a preview or
what's coming into the Google cloud
environment where we actually processing
it in real time and what you can see
here is we're creating a seven different
layers
it's 720p output 664 K audio by the way
everything that we run in Aventis is
based on api's even our own UI runs and
calls the same sets of api is to create
this type of experience and then I can
look at here I can perform all sorts of
slight insertions ad insertion to all
the blackout's I can check my channel
help so we'll collect all the data in
real time and expose that to you
everything from when we ingest the
content to decode encode packaging
encryption and publishing ad insertion
we will track everything in real time
and use that data to fix problems if
there are any issues and it seems like
there was one issue something I thought
I saw a little blip and he just alerts
will pop up automatically in real time
if there's any problems that that we
cannot be fixed
Aventis will automatically self heal
them by failing over to a different
virtual instance and then and then at
the end of the day once everything plays
we can go here and let's go ahead and
see some real video if we can switch to
to this screen by the way I can perform
the same sets of tasks great thank you
guys perform same sets of tasks off my
iPad now that looks like there's some
source ingest issues but let's see if we
click on this we should be seeing video
here shortly
those are the issues that we're seeing
in alerts so this is actually a source
that's getting rowdy from Stanford
Connecticut all the way from abc's
facility down into the Las Vegas to the
Google cloud so looks like we're having
some source ingest issues that's
from Stanford but and if you can so
that's the video playing apologies for
source ingest issues but if you can tell
if you can switch me back on a previous
screen like sure I will show you here
you can see that event assess already
detected that so if I look at my in my
alerts it's going to telling me lost
incoming stream data it's coming in and
that's why it's having a performance
issues so anyways that's the demo
apologies for a source that's coming in
it is coming like that from Stanford
Connecticut all the way through us so
wearing some playback issues on that but
that's essentially giving you an idea
how quickly can we stand up a channel
how quickly can we deploy this Texas
about 15 minutes and we can deploy event
us anywhere around the world any of
Google Cloud locations and we can stand
up 110 50 or thousands of these channels
all within 15 minutes